[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the political editor for the sunday
times caroline wheeler and the columnist
for the article ali mirage so great to
see you both good evening to you both
good evening so let's take a look then
what's making those front pages and the
eye ties together the news that the
omicron variant of covid appears to be
milder than its predecessors with the
government's announcement that there
won't be any further announcements about
restrictions in england before christmas
the daily telegraph hears there won't be
any new measures in place on new year's
eve either
the time says millions of people may
need a fourth covid jab because
protection from a booster starts to wear
off after as little as three months
the guardian carries warnings from
doctors that festive celebrations should
be kept low-key
against that backdrop the financial
times has word of a new single day
record for cases today more than 119
000.
scotland's preston journal has seen
draft proposals which if implemented
would mean ambulances there would be
operated by one trained medic and a
driver
and as we just heard the queen will pay
tribute to her late husband prince
philip in her christmas broadcast that's
on the daily mail's front page
and on that same story the express
declares queen shares pain of her loss
and the mirror also leads with her
majesty's speech and the headline always
by her side
so i'm joined by caroline wheeler and
ali mirage to go through those front
pages and caroline
similar headlines really to today's
papers um with another study out um
which suggests that the omicron variant
of covid is less severe than previous
variant so some good news headlines out
there again tomorrow
yeah it's christmas there has to be good
news there has to be a time of year
where we report happy things and it
seems that this uk health security
agency report which is out today has
delivered some welcome news again
suggesting that the variant is sort of
70 percent less likely to lead you into
hospital if you're unfortunate enough to
get the virus which is of course welcome
news given uh that it really has been
the nhs uh that all our eyes have been
on as we move into the christmas period
i mean very dire warnings even uh last
weekend from the government scientists
uh that the nhs would be overwhelmed and
we could end up with sort of three
thousand cases a day of people being
taken into hospital but this is sort of
measured i suppose by the fact that we
are still seeing record numbers of cases
and that figure 119 000 cases uh being
recorded in a day is very large and
alarming given that we know only around
one in three cases are actually
registered people test at home and they
don't upload their results onto the nhs
website so there are sort of
conservative predictions that up to 1.4
million people
could be infected right now
and of course even if a very small
fraction of those people uh get very ill
and end up in hospital that could still
put some pressure on the nhs
but what's interesting is the the really
different ways in which the newspapers
today have reported this story
some very straight talking about it
being great news others a lot more
tempered and measured
and others really focused on what this
might mean in terms of those threatened
restrictions which we've all been
writing about now for several weeks well
that's right so let's go through some of
the other front pages ali shall we
because while the eye talks about new
hope in their headline we move on to the
financial times and their first words
are cases hit record which
speaks to the other part of the story
that caroline was referring to there so
while undoubtedly it's going to be good
news if this variant is less severe
there is concern about its
transmissibility isn't there and that
that that the speed at which it's
spreading could mean that we lose that
advantage over severity
well and i think that's right and i
think that clearly you've got close to
120 000
cases within a day
which is obviously very worrying and
you're right about the transmissibility
issue the key
question for the government here or the
key issue for the government to deal
with is the potential overwhelming of
the nhs it's operating currently
at uh i think 94
uh capacity it's about five percent
higher than this time last year which is
very very
close to full capacity with no wriggle
room at all we already know that uh
there are issues already with six
million people on the waiting list and
all that entailed so i think it's a
difficult one for the government because
on one side you've got uh until now
until the uk uh scientific agent health
and security agency came out with this
report that caroline referred to which
is saying that it's 70 percent um less
likely that you will end up
in hospital with this which is a
positive thing and this follows on the
back of imperial and edinburgh also
saying similar things uh in the last 24
hours on the other side you still got
the scientists rather nervous and saying
that we should still be careful you see
this playing out in the different
approaches again being taken by
different administrations wales for
example has been pretty clear that as of
boxing day we're going to be back to the
rule of six in wales uh you can't have
meetings of more than 30 people inside
two meter distancing rule etc with all
that entails for the hospitality
industry and now scotland's saying that
it's going to be closing nightclubs for
three weeks i take a personal interest
in nightclubs as a house music dj um and
i feel that you know on things like that
we could have done with coded
vaccination could have been the answer
to keeping some of these things open so
i do worry about it i do worry about the
impacts on the economy and i think that
the government at the moment has made it
clear that it's not going to announce
anything new until next week ali
everything that you said that was
interesting but possibly one of the
things that stood out was the fact that
you're a house music dj we'll have to
come back to that another time i'm
really interested to learn about that
sometime and quickly just take a look at
the ft i've just noticed that the
picture there is of a christmas shopper
walking past a poster saying santa says
relax which is quite interesting and it
actually leads us on quite neatly to the
daily telegraph because
they're they are picking up on this
dilemma that the the government of
westminster has over what to do about
england as you say ally wales northern
ireland and scotland are all have all
announced that there will be some
tougher restrictions after christmas
england not so so far and we've been
it's been confirmed today that we won't
hear before christmas about that the
daily telegraph suggesting that there
may not be new curbs even by new year's
eve caroline
yeah that's right they've interpreted
this as being a sort of big boost for
the sort of anti-lockdown campaigners of
which uh much of the time the
telegraph's very much been on that side
of lifting restrictions very much on the
side of sort of freedom and the
libertarian argument and
their interpretation of the uh reports
that we've had from all of those medical
agencies over the last 24 hours is that
that now means that it's less likely
that we're going to get any form of
restrictions this
side of the new year now i spoke to
people in number 10 about this today as
you can imagine
government's pretty much winding up
ahead of christmas uh a few people being
tomorrow but largely uh people were
finishing today and yes they're very
clear that there isn't going to be an
announcement there were some rumors that
we could have ended up with a boxing day
press conference and preparation for a
recall of parliament next week but
actually those plans now seem to have
been put on ice for the time being
there's not going to be any further data
as far as i understand published
between now and monday
but they are still saying that
everything is very much on the table and
they'll review everything
when they come back to work
on monday which obviously is a bank
holiday and tuesday's a bank holiday too
um but they are a little bit worried
because so far what they've noticed in
particularly in the capital if people's
behavior has really changed in response
to the omicron variant and it's
certainly evidence if you see the
restaurants and pubs around the country
i've certainly noticed it on social
media people putting up photographs
showing that restaurants and pubs are
pretty empty for this time of year and i
think one of the things that concerns
them is that that behavior might change
after christmas lots of people very much
sort of self-regulating and
self-isolating in the hope that they can
still see their loved ones this
christmas uh obviously having missed out
on that last year
and that really christmas is a time for
families and new year's is time for
friends and what they're worried about
is if there's a sudden sea change and
people suddenly start going out and
being a little bit less cautious
that that might have an impact so that's
very much something that they are going
to want to keep
under consideration as we head into
those new year celebrations at the end
of next weekend
and
interestingly that that caroline that
you were mentioning
how people are choosing to behave ali do
you think that's how the government
wants to to stick
that they hope that people take personal
responsibility without them having to
introduce any regulations
well i think that's probably true and i
think we're going to have to wait and
see what the government does i think
this data is clearly going to point in
the direction of hopefully no further
restrictions and i think
to be honest with you the prime
minister's in a difficult position uh to
balance not only his cabinet but also
his party and also people in the country
now that have grown increasingly tired
of restrictions i mean the yougov poll
out a few days ago showed that a lot of
people will really not be
happy with any further restrictions at
all and the whole point about having a
rapid booster roller and now half the
population has been boosted is that we
can actually try and carry on with our
lives being sensible but but getting on
with what we need to do and look i give
you two reference points caroline
mentions people changing their behavior
i'll give you two reference points i was
out at my favorite pakistani restaurant
in white chapel two nights ago it was
empty literally empty and normally the
place is packed you can't even
get a seat in there for love nor money
the other reference point is today i was
in the city of london talking to my hair
stylist a chap by the name of gem who
was sorry that was not a joke um i do
have a hair stylist
and he told me that um
he told me that basically
today in the city of london he since
nine o'clock in the morning had five
customers i mean i was surprised that he
was he was still open uh but such is his
is his commitment to his profession uh
that he uh he felt it was incumbent upon
him to remain open but five customers in
a day and the point that he made very
clearly was that whilst the government
is rightly helping the hospitality
industry with grants about six thousand
pounds those in allied industries
hairdressing others etc are not getting
anything and the problem with this
self-imposed
guidance from the government is it's
neither one thing nor the other now i
don't say that it's easy for the
government i think it's very hard
particularly on the back of christmas
party gate last year where there's a
certain lack of credibility again okay
with what the prime minister can come
out with but you know i i do worry about
the impacts on the economy well yes and
turn into the guardian caroline their
headline is keep your celebration small
doctors urge britons i mean
is it likely that people will start
listening to other voices because there
is a certain
i was going to say paralysis but that's
mark drakeford's word
the welsh first minister about the
westminster government but but certainly
there's not full agreement in the
cabinet or that's what we're hearing is
that what you understand
yeah absolutely and i think you know
it's concerning these kind of mixed
messages that you get
and that's been very prevalent now for a
number of days that we're seeing very
much the politicians say one thing and
the scientists saying another and indeed
in the guardian they make the point that
what stage is saying is that actually
you need there to be a 90 less risk of
ending up in hospital
to really have an impact in terms of the
hospitalization level and not reaching
beyond the peak that we saw uh last
january and of course i think it does
come down to people people's trust you
know should we be trusting the
politicians should we be trusting the
scientists who's right who's wrong you
know a real feeling i think after that
rebellion last week when the prime
minister faced down a hundred of his own
mps who voted in the opposing division
lobby that actually some of these
decisions are being taken for political
reasons rather than because of the
science which they said that they would
be guided by but it's very difficult if
you speak to people within government
what they've said time and time again is
we just simply don't know enough to make
these decisions at the moment whereas of
course scientists are forever modeling
and forecasting what might come
okay well it's going to be really
interesting a few days now and after
christmas isn't it we're going to take a
break right there though lots more to
talk about coming up after the break
including we'll have details of how the
queen plans to pay tribute to prince
philip in her christmas speech join us
after the break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight caroline wheeler
and ali mirage and um ali the queen
makes a number of the front pages as
well doesn't she um daily mail is the
one that you've picked out um looking
ahead to the queen's speech
indeed and it's uh obviously a big
moment for i think the nation uh every
year on christmas day at 3 p.m it's a
it's a fixture certainly in our
household and i think in households
across the country and the queen and
utter professional next year will be 70
years on the throne and it's been a very
difficult uh personal time for the queen
this year with the loss of her husband
of 73 years prince philip back in april
who was a real public servant gave so
much to the nation and also lived by
that mantra of sacrifice and giving
something in service thinking about
others more than himself i think it's a
great loss to the queen and i think
we're all very grateful for her
unwavering support for the nation and
utter professionalism and of course
caroline if if she does indeed talk
about
the loss of her husband there will be
people up and down the country who have
lost loved ones this year it will no
doubt resonate with a lot of people
yeah absolutely and i think that's
probably well intended by the palace to
really kind of underline that the queen
is you know among us she's one of you
know she's a part of the community and
she suffers and she feels pain in the
same way that everybody else has done
through this very difficult time with
people losing loved ones uh through
covert and other illnesses uh you know
throughout the the time that we've had
and i think it will be an interesting
queen speech just simply because uh it's
been a moment of sort of national
emergency now for the last year uh since
the pandemic started we thought we were
coming out of it we've obviously ended
up going back into it again towards the
end of the year and of course the queen
herself has changed her plan she won't
be having that big family christmas
herself which must be you know very
difficult for her given that she's lost
her husband this year so there'll be a
lot for her to reflect upon
yes that's right and we learned today
that she will be spending christmas at
windsor with charles and camilla i think
that's right and very quickly we've only
got about 30 seconds ellie are you able
to sum up the story about champagne on
the front of the financial times for us
quickly
yeah well typical financial times that
it wouldn't be the financials without an
index this is the liv x index of
champagne and it's saying that there's
been a 33
bounce in the price of certain vintages
of champagne apparently 2008 2012 were
particularly good years i can't say i'm
a champagne expert if it was
non-alcoholic slur i'd be all over it
well i'm sure there's a story somewhere
in the papers on that and we'll try and
find it for 11 30 but for the moment
ally and caroline thanks both very much
indeed and just to let you know that
because we are now in the festive period
there's no extended news review tonight
but caroline and ali will be back with
us at 11 30 for another half an hour
press a preview so we'll see them then